المرحله الثانيه عام 2021 تمثلت بنشر
صحيفه الجاردن لما اعتبرته كشفا عن عدد
وفيات العاملين في انشاءات قطر استعدادا
لمونديال 2020
نفسها اعترفت بان الارقام لم تكن صحيحه
كان هناك تقدير جذافي للعدد الاجمالي
للوفيات منذ البديل بانشاء البنيه التحتيه
لكاس العالم لقد وقعوا في خطا لم يقع هذا
العدد من الوفيات قطر تتعرض لهجمه هي
الاشراس اعلاميه بالمقارنه مع دول الكبرى
نسيم وروسيا وفقا لدراسه اعدتها هيئه
مراقبه اخلاق ولوائح الفيفا وعلى الرغم من
الاصلاحات النوعيه التي اجرتها قطر وكان
على راسها اصلاحات نظام الكفاله ورفع الحد
الادنى للاجور وحمايتها ومنح العمال
المهاجرين حق تقديم الممثلين عنهم كسابقه
هي الاولى من جهات الخليج الا ان تغطيه
هذه الاصلاحات في الاعلام الغربي جاءت
متواضعه
[موسيقى]
لا تنتهي بموجب القانون هناك تحديات في
التنفيذ ولكن الان اصبح لدى العاملين عقد
شفاف هناك في الواقع حد ادنى للاجور مبني
على معايير محدده ودون تمييز بما في ذلك
عاملات المنازل وهو الاول في العالم من
هذا الجانب لديهم قوانين خاصه بالاجهاد
بسبب الحراره يمكنهم تغيير وظائفهم وهم
احرار في اختيار مكان السكن لم يعد هناك
وضع يكون فيه العامل مملوكا لفرد اخر
وبينما لا يزال معظم العمال يعيشون في
مساكن فقد تم تطويرها ويتم اعاده بنائها
بشكل تدريجي ولم تعد المساكن ذات الحاله
السيئه قيد الاستخدام